تستعد
لاستقبال سنه جديده وهما في حاله حرب
تقترب من اكمال عامها الاول يحل فصل
الشتاء وتنخفض درجات الحراره الى مستويات
قياسيه ما يعقد سعر المعارك في ارض
الميدان في ظل هذه الاجواء يتحدث الطرفان
عن المفاوضات مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
اليكسي ارستوفيتش جددت ثوابت بلاده وهي
استعاده وشبه جزيره القرم وكافه الاراضي
التي سيطرت عليها روسيا في المقابل بالمتر
بيسكوب المتحدث وباسم الكريمرن يقولوا انه
لا يمكن ان تكون هناك اي خطه سلام
اوكرانيا لا تاخذ بعين الاعتبار ما سماها
حقائق اليوم وهي ضم المناطق الاربع لروسيا
واضاف ان اي خطه لا تعترف بهذه الحقيقه لا
يمكن تسميتها خطه السلام ياتي هذا في سياق
زاد فيه الحديث عن المفاوضات قال الرئيس
الروسي الذيمرت قبل ايام ان بلاده مستعده
للتفاوض مع كل اطراف بشان مقبوله لكن هذه
الاطراف ترفض ذلك واشار الى ان جميع
النزاعات المسلحه تنتهي بالدبلوماسيه حديث
بوتين عن حلول مقبول وعن الدبلوماسيه فتح
الباب على مصرعه لتكنات بشان مدى استعداده
لتسويه في اوكرانيا لكن السلطات في كياب
استقبلت هذه التصريحات بريبه شديده وقالت
انما تفعله القوات الروسيه في الميدان
يؤكد عكس ما يقوله المسؤولون الروس وقدم
وزير الخارج الاوكراني ديميتر كوليبا
تفاصيل خطه لعقد قمه سلام تحدث
سابقا قال ان افضل مكان لانعقاد قمه
السلام هو مقر الامم المتحده لكنه اشترت
مثوله روسيا امام محكمه جرائم حرب
للمشاركه فيها رده موسكو بسرعه بالتاكيد
على انها لن تشارك الا بشروطها قبل دم
روسيا اقاليموهان
الماضي تحدث الرئيس الاوكراني شهره مارس
عن امكانيه التفاوض اذا انسحبت القوات
الروسيه من هذه المناطق ولم يشر الى وضع
شبه جزيره القرم لكن موقفه اصبح اكثر
تصلبا بعد قرار الدم واعلن انه لن يتفاوض
في وجود الرئيس بوتين قد يبدي زينسكي بعد
التصلب لكن موقفه يتاثر بمن يقدم له
مساعدات ضخمه خصوصا الولايات المتحده وقد
ذكرت الواشنطن بوست شهرا نوفمبر ان
الاداره الامريكيه طلبت منزلينسكي اظهار
بعض المرونه بشان المفاوضات حتى الان لا
يبدو من خلال مواقف الطرفين ان المفاوضات
ستبدا قريبا ويبقى انتظاره تطورات الوضع
في ارض المعركه وتاثير العقوبات الغربيه
على روسيا وقدره الغرب خصوصا واشنطن على
الاستمرار في دعم اكياس لمعرفه متى
ستعقدها هذه المفاوضات وباي شروط